[Music]
all right let's go to paula in columbia
s don't tattoo on your face that's weird
but hey paula what's going on
hey dr john how are you i'm good and you
i'm all right
uh oh that doesn't sound good what's
going on
um
my husband died three weeks ago after an
eight month battle with cancer paul the
paul i'm so sorry
three weeks ago
tell me about him yeah
um
he was awesome
yeah um
the happiest person you've met
um
kind wonderful
had great
life and has done
a bunch of wonderful things in his life
um
and was just at a point in his life
where he was sharing those with other
people teaching them things he knew
um throughout his cancer treatments he
went into every one of them with a smile
on his face he was
everyone's favorite patient
um
his goals were to
eat sleep drink and
um you know
pick cancer
and mine were to find all the best
treatments and read all the medical
journals and he never once gave up
he was amazing
and three weeks ago
it caught him huh
it did
um
can i just tell you um i'm
so sorry paula
thank you
i can tell on your voice that you love
love that guy and you won the
you won the husband lottery with that
one
what was his name you know i i got a
card that said that i'd said it to a
friend not you know when we were early
on kind of doing that thing people do
about talking about their husbands
things they do and i said you know what
i got a good one
there really wasn't anything to complain
about and that was the coolest card to
get hey i got a good one like it's like
a whispering like secret guess what guys
i found a hundred dollars under my house
yeah i got i got a really good one even
after 13 years
what was his name what was his name
his name was david david don't make sure
we say his name out loud and honor him
that's awesome
oh yeah actually so
i we have a son okay um he is five five
five
and we say his name every day and we
sing them and we
talk about him and we have pictures
charles connor
put pictures on our hat you know in
little areas in our house and we've he
brought his dad to show and tell last
week because he had to pick a word that
began with dee and to use her dad so
he is doing awesome now um and
at the beginning of the journey the
first three months we didn't tell him
anything but we found great resources
and we were able to bring him on the
journey with us he met nurses and
ate at the hospital cafeteria and he
just
he knew his dad was sick but it helped
him with compassion and empathy and he
is the coolest kid and part of that was
because he had the coolest dad yeah
so and
i know where you're going with this so
before you even say it i'm gonna tell
you and
he had the coolest mom too
yes he did he does he's got a mom who
loves him and mom who shows up
and a mom but i was loved his dad too
and that's magic i was
i was more the operational parent
i know you're put
listen
i am the fun dad and you know what
wouldn't happen
if we'd have no electricity in my house
or food
we'd have a really cool fire outside and
we'd write our names in the yard with
the lawn mower but we'd have no food
right so it takes both and they your son
won with you too
here in lies the problem how
do i navigate the upcoming years so that
this awesome kid can grow into
an awesome man
without his dad around yeah
we have a huge community and great men
in it and there are men in his lives but
there's not that
fun in the house
and around him constantly
what a great hard heartbreaking question
and thank you for trusting me that i
know it's even hard to say out loud
every time you have to say those words
without dad the whole thing
just pulls that scab off again
so here's the thing
i'll answer your question
but i'm gonna answer it with a caveat
okay okay this is
a next year question
okay
you're three weeks out
and as a planner and as a controller
and as somebody who loves people who are
lots of fun but you
you were put on this earth to make sure
they don't all drive off the cliff
together
um you are doing your best to tie up
every loose end
right and to control what you control
because a grenade just went off in your
heart
and in your home
and trying not to control as much i know
i know i know i know uh and bill's got
to get paid right life insurance has to
i mean all that stuff has to happen and
there's still going to be a roof leak
and things like that
but
you're worrying on a 20-year challenge
right now
and there is still smoke coming out of
that house
and so for the next three months the
next six months
the greatest gift you can give your son
is that you be honest about your grief
and you cry with him and when you're sad
and you're lonely you hug him
but also you don't make him responsible
for your wellness and your healing
and that mom takes care of mom
and that doesn't mean a lot of that that
doesn't mean faking it or flexing or
that means
you got someone to talk to you got
people to cry you've got people you can
call when you need to be away from your
son and you just need to go for a walk
in the woods with a buddy like you know
what i mean
it sounds like you have a great
community that's the gift you can give
him okay
um
downstream you're right
little boys need models of men
they do
and
teaching
integrity honesty grit kindness and
strength
those are not gender specific things
he'll be fun because he's fun
he'll be bonkers because he's bonkers
you can still teach him what strength
looks like even if it's a different kind
of strength than the one maybe dad would
have shown him
and by the way when you tell stories of
dad
they will become almost more powerful
than him
so stories of dad's strength and dad's
character and dad's integrity will take
root in his heart
as will watching you be a person of
integrity and strength and character
and you calling those things out
explicitly
and so i don't want you to think your
your son is gonna struggle because dad
passed away that's a trauma you know
that right that's a great tragedy he's
gonna struggle he's gonna have
challenges and when i say struggle or
challenges i don't mean like
ah it's all not like that but his life's
gonna be harder than mine was because my
dad's still here okay and he had an
incredible father i don't i don't want
to mince that
and
he is gonna be incredibly blessed by you
and so i don't want you to think that
suddenly there's these things that you
can't teach him that's not true
he will need male models
he'll need men in his life that will
take him out i said that kind of weird i
just want to like say i should have said
he needs male models i made that whole
thing weird he'll need models of men in
his life right that will take him
fishing and take him hunting or take him
to do computer what i don't know what
he's into but whatever he's into that
would be important and those guys will
come
that's for later
that's for later
the important thing right now is to sit
and just be still and grieve and i'm so
sorry
so sorry
the sitting part is hard it is it is but
what i'm going to tell you is you can't
run from
this and as a controller you're used to
running from it
because that's what control gives us
are you set up financially are you all
okay there
we um became 100 debt free
a month before he passed away wow
it was a challenge
and
you know day one there's always a
person who's going home and there's
somebody who's not
and so
david begrudgingly followed me
the entire time but
we did it together
and being able to look back and say that
we did it together
is way cooler than
after the fact so we're
we're okay
i have an amazing
boss an amazing ceo an amazing company
awesome
good for you um good for them awesome
we're
we're good it's just hold on hold on a
lot
and you're not good
you lost your best friend
and it's okay to not be good
it's okay to not be good it's okay to
not be strong it's okay to not be in
control
thank you
the world doesn't need any more strong
sprinters
right dave always says uh my dave always
says he reads the tortoise and the hair
every year and the tortoise wins every
time
your little boy
paula
is really lucky to have you
real lucky to have you he's really lucky
to have the community he's in and he's
really lucky to have spent five magical
years with the magical incredible dad
you are correct
and so
sit in the memory and the love of your
husband
sit in the pain in the hurt of you lost
your best friend and co-pilot you're
forever guy
sit in the grief that your son lost his
dad
sitting the joy that man he got to spend
five years with somebody who was just
magic
and then be about the slow
slow
process of healing
don't hide your grieving from your son
don't bury him with it either
put people in your life that will call
you out on making sure you're eating
making sure you're walking making sure
you're going to work
making sure your son's got somewhere to
go on the weekends and go play and be
around people his own age
make sure he's got a counselor that will
walk with him
um
that'll be different than you more than
likely
and recognize this this isn't a sprint
this isn't something you can wrap your
arms on you can't control grief you
can't wrap it up and hold it really
tight it'll it'll
pull you under water
to breathe through it
it's so hard and i'm so so sorry
and by the way there's no rules to grief
it'll hit you at weird times and weird
moments there's no expectations you have
to grieve like this in this way in this
amount of time
people are going to try to shape your
grief to make them comfortable
they don't get them
your story is your story and your sons
is your sons and you all are in this
together
and what an extraordinary testament to
the world
your husband
who fought valiantly who smiled all the
way to the end
and who handed that baton
of
being free financially to you he just
made it
what an incredible testament so david we
salute you brother
and we all hope to see you sometime and
high five you man thanks for being a
husband who loved his wife and loved his
kid
thanks for the call paula thank you so
much